[Musique]
au train les habitants de la région
parisienne sont enfin fixés aujourd'hui
sur le parcours défini le district
parisiens avaient à choisir soit la
ligne qui ré de la défense jusqu à
cergy-pontoise soit pas d'air au train
du tout en définitive il ya une
demi-heure le district a voté par 33
voix contre 11
il a confirmé la création de cette ligne
le choix était long et difficile claude
carré et pierre moscovici vous explique
pourquoi
[Musique]
250 kilomètres à l'heure depuis six ans
et aérotrain expérimental fait des
allers-retours solitaire près d'orléans
moyen de transport ultra moderne
il est maintenant parfaitement au point
reste une question va-t-on bientôt
construire une première ligne
commerciale le gouvernement a dit oui
l'aérotrain est une invention française
il faut donc l'exploiter d'abord chez
nous pour notre confort et pour la faire
connaître à l'étranger et la revendre
avec bénéfice pour la france une ligne
sera donc créé près de paris cergy
pontoise la défense mais après la
décision du gouvernement le district
parisien qui s'occupe de l'aménagement
de toute la région parisienne doit
donner son accord
l'avenir de l'aérotrain se joue donc ici
dans cette salle au conseil
d'administration du district des
conseillers sont allés à orléans visitée
l'aérotrain et écoutez les explications
de son inventeur l'ingénieur bertin mais
il était mécontent
pourquoi disent-ils la région parisienne
seul devrait-elle financer aérotrain
dans la promotion concerne toute la
france alors que cette ligne ne
correspond pas aux besoins des usagers
de la banlieue
le gouvernement les a rassurés sur ce
point le district ne supportera pas seul
le financement de la ligue mais les élus
sont aussi partagées il avait d'autres
projets ceux du sud ou de l'est sont
contre les routes reims de l'ouest pour
regarder ses cartes
au départ le district préféré une ligne
à l'est entre le futur aéroport de
roissy et orly coût 600 millions de
francs
c'était trop cher pour l'état et le 29
juillet dernier le gouvernement
choisissait à l'ouest la ligne
cergy-pontoise la défense cette ligne
sera construite où il n'y aura aucun
aérotrain le choix donc est difficile
voici cette ligne coût 3 117 millions de
francs mais dans cette région le
district avait déjà prévu une nouvelle
voie ferrée qui dit il dessert mieux
cette banlieue caennais au train rapide
qui ne s'arrête pas en chemin
de plus cette voie ferrée ne goûtait que
133 millions de francs au district
argent qui sera reversée à l'aérotrain
un héros train qui ne pourra fonctionner
qu'en 1976 un an plus tard que le train
mais l'aérotrain sera une chance pour la
promotion des villes nouvelles
sète hérault train sera le frère de
celui-ci filmé pour la première fois
gomes la ville moteurs linéaires 200
kilomètres à l'heure en croisière
quelles seront les répercussions de
cette nouvelle ligne pour les usagers
les opinions des élus là aussi sont
divisés parce que nous pensons que cergy
pontoise qui est une ville nouvelle
risque de devenir si elle s'est ralliée
par un moyen très rapide à la défense la
ville dortoir la défense que les emplois
soient à la défense et que l'on fasse
mal était là le contre schéma directeur
l'agente aedian et nous sommes inquiets
également en ce qui concerne nos propres
finances car en effet l'exploitation de
sète hérault train sera coûteux il est
pas évident qu'ils puissent absorber le
nombre de voyageurs qui nécessaire
d'absorber et nous risquons peut-être à
terme et à moyen terme de nous voir
contraint de financer en plus de
l'aérotrain une voie de chemin de fer
classique
nous ne voulons pas que pour les
populations la région par le truchement
des impôts payent la soul à la kass
danno d'une opération qui est
intéressant nationalement mais qui l'est
beaucoup moins pour la jambe et il faut
un aérotrain il vaut mieux l'aérotrain
cergy-pontoise que de padt aérotrain du
tout d'autant plus que la r30 cergy
pontoise est extrêmement important il
s'agit en effet d'une ville nouvelle
il faut lui donner des moyens de
transport modernes la ligne qui lierait
cergy à la défense alors que la défense
est maintenant saturé au point de vue
bureau aurait pour but par un système de
bipolarisation d'apporter à
cergy-pontoise des emplois nouveaux et
par conséquent tant au point de vue
transport qu'au point de vue de la
création d'emplois nouveaux qui est la
vocation du district la ligne de
cergy-pontoise répond à ces conditions
c'est la raison pour laquelle issue
favorable
[Musique]